I make four movie clips with our top ten
movies of 2013 Cheers
number 10 captain phillips paul
greengrass director of board supremacy
you 1993 uses dummy drama style to the
great effect in this film Tom Hanks gets
a brilliant performance as a casted
protecting his ship from Somali pirates
dark intense and realistic captain
Phillips will keep you on the edge of
your seat number 9 frozen this along
with tangled is proving that Disney can
make great family films without the
Pixar brand aside from being a lovely
family film this also has a strong
female lead which we'd love to see an
animated place number 8 blue Jasmine say
what you will about Woody Allen the man
can turn out incredible films at a fast
pace even though he's starting to look
like an old cartoon Cate Blanchett
delivers Oscar buzz in this funny tragic
character study number 7 the wolf of
Wall Street
Oh Marty and Leo back together again for
the fifth time was possibly the best
movie of both their careers yeah I said
it equal parts hilarious and tragic Leo
Ahmadi are at the top of their form
number 6 brush the beef between Niki
Lauda and James Hunt is one for the ages
Ron Howard delivers a slick and exciting
film that features a lot of style and
awesome ray sequences I'm a huge Formula
one fan and this movie did not
disappoint
number five bud the Meccano song
continues this film was directed and
written by the brilliant jeff nichols
who also made shotgun stories and each
shelter Matthew McConaughey's
with a guy who really steals the show is
15 year old Tye Sheridan number 4
catching fire while Hunger Games was
great this is a way superior sequel
Deborah Lawrence continues to kill it as
Katniss Everdeen Duff Francis Lawrence
did an amazing job with this and he's
set for Mockingjay part 1 & 2 which is
really exciting
number 3 12 years of slave this movie
has Oscar buzz written all over it
Steve McQueen is quickly becoming one of
the best directors working today
shame hunger and now 12 years of slave
Annapoorna film that is sometimes so
brutally realistic it is hard to watch
this is essential viewing for everyone
number 2 American hustle 3 issuer's
David O Russell's three kings I Heart
Huckabees the fighter silver linings
playbook and now American hustle this
one stars Christian Bale Jeremy Renner
Amy Adams Bradley Cooper and Jennifer
Lawrence this is a con movie where the
con come secondary to the characters and
their brilliant performances number one
gravity alfonso cuarón has never been a
stranger to ambition but this is ground
breaking
filmmaking I have to be honest I thought
that this film was just gonna be really
incredible to look at but what surprised
me the most was the bullets performance
I thought it was incredible and it
really took me by surprise
state-of-the-art technology aids an
engaging and affecting story a film like
this keeps the theatrical experience
alive it was a great year for movies
leave a comment below and let us know
what your favorites were thanks for
watching I'm beg for movie clips and
have a happy new year